Lonnie is in Oahu Hawaii
hey Lonnie how are you I am great thank
you so much for taking my call
sure what's up okay so this is a tax
question so my husband and I started
doing our taxes online and it turned out
that we show that it we are gonna have
to owe federal and state about 1400 and
federal 700 and state and we do not have
the funds at all to be able to pay those
what we owe and so just trying to get
some suggestion on what you think we
should do how we should pay it we're on
baby step number one only so we looked
at the options that was either during
the payment plan but that of course
comes with fees and interest and
penalties for trying to acquire
household income only my husband working
his so our house would income is about
38,000 okay the kids or what hi yes I'm
at home okay what they're young yeah
he's working forty hours yep and okay
the first thing is this when you cannot
pay your taxes you file your tax return
anyway because there's also a failure to
file penalty that is in addition to the
failure to pay penalty it doesn't keep
you from it doesn't keep you from having
a penalty it just lowers the amount of
penalty by paying on it by filing on
time so before okay on or before April
15th I would wait until right at April
15th to file between now and then I'm
gonna sell everything in sight we need a
big garage sale we need to figure out
what else we can sell what we can put on
Craigslist or whatever it is and we need
to start moving some stuff out of there
the second thing we need to do is your
husband needs to start doing some kind
of extra work at night delivering pizzas
or whatever to make some extra money
really really really fast
now do you have your $1,000 we we
actually did we had it but then we got
into we're actually traveling for my
husband's work and so we hit hard plays
and we actually had to use it so we
could eat but we're trying to look back
on putting it back in there how did you
hit a hard place traveling through your
husband's work okay because we're living
out of a hotel and I guess are trying to
eat out of a hotel ever since we don't
have a kitchen and trying to cook and
stay on a budget it's been kind of hard
to feed three of us so we've we've I had
I guess spent more money on eating than
then we were okay so what why are you
where do you guys live normally so we
actually live on Oahu but we're here in
California for three months for my
husband's job he's a he works with
federal government okay and then give
him another they don't give him enough
to take care of his family home while
he's there in AB addition to pay in my
hole $38,000 is he military only no so
he's a federal police officer yeah three
civilian law enforcement on and he
didn't say give him $50 a day okay so
he's supposed to travel without his
family is the idea then because that's
not that's not set up to support a
family obviously hmm and how many
children do you have just one two three
okay all right yeah being away for work
for three months is really really
difficult
from the little hard part to is the fact
that you know there's more I want to do
but just because we're here a movie will
be back on Oahu and at the end of this
month so I'm planning on hitting the
ground running of course selling
everything I possibly think of my
husband I found out okay can he work
security on his off-duty hours legally
um he says it's a conflict of interest
with his job if he works another kind of
well it's not it's all right for a
regular police
officer they do it all the time legally
but I don't know what the federal and
what the what branch is in or what
they've done with him here but so
alright the point is we've got to get
your income up if he's only working 40
hours he can pick up some kind of extra
income doing something somewhere somehow
because I want you to pay this tax bill
super super super fast okay and that way
you don't even put money into the
emergency fund just to focus on paying
off this the IRS well yeah you getting
to get thousand dollars you're in a
dadgum a hotel so yeah you need to get
your thousand dollars back and then but
but one month of delivering pizzas on
the side when he gets home and this is
paid okay but he's every night and but
he's got to get his income up and you
guys got to get on a written budget and
you don't accidentally end up in a hard
place you all made the decision and I
don't know that I blame you being away
for three months from your kid is a
tough thing I get that but you all made
the decision to move into a situation
you couldn't afford when you made the
decision to go to California with him so
the hard place didn't happen to you you
caused it and that's what you've got to
do is look at that and go oh we can't do
that
and I can't be away from him for three
months he needs a different job or we've
got to talk to his supervisor about I
got to put my family up if we're gonna
go over there for three months or we're
gonna pay this price and pretend like
we're a military family and he's on
deployment for three months and we're
gonna suck it up but you can't just
wander over there and go oh we're broke
surprise fifty dollars a day won't feed
a family that's not a surprise in
California that's not it's not a shock
so that's the kind of stuff you got to
get out get your head around and I'm not
fussing at you I'm saying you know one
of the things that happens when people
start handling money well is they decide
to happen to their money instead of
their money happening to them and that's
my concern with our conversation it
feels like this is all happening to you
that somehow you it's not in your
control and it's all in your control
it's all your decisions now from this
point forward you got to have that point
now you may be there till the end the
month it may be a tough month and then
we start hard well
get back to Oahu that'll be fine sell
everything in sight take two jobs you
guys go crazy and let's get these taxes
paid and let's get up and get moving and
get through the rest of these debts and
then begin to address his long-term
income potential and your household
income potential